-It's the end of the week, and that's usually when
I catch up with some personal stuff.
I check my inbox, I return some e-mails,
and, of course, I send out Thank You Notes.
And I was running a bit behind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'd like to write out some Thank You Notes right now
if that's okay with you.
Roots, can you -- Thank you.
♪♪
Appreciate it.
Thank you, appetizers that come in threes,
for guaranteeing that this date
is gonna get awkward real quick.
[ Applause ]
-For you. -For you.
-No, no, no. Go ahead. Go ahead.
-I'm not even that hungry.
♪♪
Thank you, door-knockers,
for being like if my front door got a nipple ring.
[ Applause ]
-Hey, don't kink-shame.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Dream from "The Sandman,"
for looking like if Tom Brady came out of retirement
to play for My Chemical Romance.
[ Applause ]
Okay.
♪♪
Thank you, suitcases, for being a great way
to carry every item of clothing except suits.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, "The Bachelorette's" Gabby and Rachel,
for looking like I tried to draw the Bush twins from memory.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Almost...
♪♪
-Thank you, apple crumble,
for being a muffin that took off its Spanx.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-"Ahh! Finally!
Are you gonna eat that appetizer?"
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, acorns,
for being hazelnuts that went to Paris.
Ooh! -Ooh.
[ Applause ]
-"Oui, oui!" -"Oh, oui oui, Mr. Squirrel!"
-[ Laughs ]
-"Bonjour."
♪♪
-Thank you, riding lawnmowers, for convincing dads
it's a good idea to drink four beers
and then climb on top of an upside-down helicopter.
There you have it. Those are my Thank You Notes.